what's your what's the typical audition
like whether it's LA or New York can you
walk us through yeah and there I mean in
my experience they've been pretty
similar on both coasts you you get the
sides anywhere from the night before to
couple days before out here actually I
got one like three hours before and so I
had to learn quick but you get the sides
you study them do whatever your prep
work is you know however you can get to
you where you need to be and then you
show up 10-15 minutes early just to be
there on time you know sit in the room
with three or four other guys who look
exactly like you read over your lines
and then when you're in the room you're
in there maybe depending on the size of
the role and how much material you have
to do maybe like five minutes sometimes
you know for initial auditions and a lot
of times like it's kind of a good sign
if they give you some some direction
it's not always like oh you did that the
wrong way sometimes it's just it could
even be you did it the right way now we
just want to see could you take
direction and so that's I mean when you
get a direction in the room just make
sure that you take it and give them
something different because that's what
they want to see and then yeah you
normally do it anyway I've done it 1 2 3
times normally each scene and then just
you know thank you you leave and try to
forget it immediately that's that's the
the hardest part of auditions is before
you're building up to a year like this
this could be awesome if I get it this
could be life-changing that's good and
then you have to leave it all in the
room and just forget it because you'll
drive yourself crazy if you keep
thinking about every audition that what
if what if what if I get this one you
know and you sit by your phone and you
keep waiting so it's the biggest piece
of advice is just forget it after each
audition you know
so if you get the sides three days
beforehand how much time are you
spending on it I realized three hours
beforehand it's gonna be a yeah I mean I
I definitely if you have it at least a
day or two ahead of time
memorize it make sure you get off book
because that shows that you have that
capability to of if there's a page
change the day that you're shooting you
can memorize it you know if you get it a
couple days ahead of time and are
memorized there they might be like why
why can't you do that you know but then
the other preparation everyone has their
own process depending on what the role
is if it's a comedic role that's pretty
close to me
most of the preparation is just one
memorizing it and then to doing it in
the situation that you'll be in the room
so sorry
so like most of the time you're going to
be standing for a scene so do it with a
reader so that you can you know feel
like you're in the room so that that's
not the first time you're doing it on
its feet if it's a if it's a more
in-depth dramatic role then I'll do some
book work on it and you know get you do
whatever I need to do to get me into
that character but a lot of times I'm
going in for guys pretty close to me you
know
you